(typing)
- What's up with your headset?
- What's up with
your old face Anders?
- No.
- Or should I say Blonders?
That's funny, why don't
you go back in your area?
- I just saw you
lick your microphone.
- No you didn't.
- What is that?
- This is my office space,
you're intruding my
office space right now.
- Oh my god that's booze.
- Get out of here!
- No, no that's booze.
- Stop it!
- Oh, look at here,
Mr. Cold turkey put
a mini booze bottle
in his headset?
- I really like your ingenuity,
but destroy the prototype.
- No, that's mine,
you know how many minutes
of tinker that took me?
That took me like
seven minutes to make.
- We took an oath, alright?
- Yeah, you're not special.
- I am special,
that's why I took
all those special
classes in high school.
Why do you think you
can boss me around, huh?
Slim Shady.